we got to leave you some good vibes
courtesy of ariana grande and rupaul's
drag waste contestant got mick yes while
promoting her rem beauty makeup line
ariana got her face done all drag style
by got milk and honestly the video is
just it's just six minutes of pure joy
as fans watch ari try try to become a
youtuber take a look and we'll see you
tomorrow
yeah i was like are you a youtuber
because i was like i was like do you
have an intro like are you always
[Music]
hey no
hi guys it is me got me no idea what's
going on but we thought it'd be fun to
just sit down
kiki together and get in to rem beauty
yes that was great thank you so we both
put on a light beat a light little base
a light base this is
used a bunch of products that i can't
show them yet so i want them to know
that there's much to look forward to
i'll show them when the time comes
base this is my face to start and i
think we're just gonna play with it and
talk and show you guys our favorite
products from the line yeah and i'm
gonna ask you why they're your favorite
products because some of them i need to
know i think i should just i want to put
it on you yeah i'll make you a little
draggy jug love that hey guys
are you redoing it hey guys it's me
like every 30 minutes
hey guys it's me by the way again still
me looks like hey guys i'm sorry mo
i don't do this
i'm literally gonna cry too
i don't
oh my god i'm new here